This morning Boeing.
max nine jets are all grounded,
meaning hundreds of flights
forced to be canceled
as investigators are urgently
trying to figure out
why a big chunk of an Alaska Airlines
plane tore off mid-flight.
A huge hole
and a ton of questions left behind.
Some of the new details today
and the month before.
Friday's terrifying.
20 minutes in the air.
A pressurization
warning light had gone off three times.
That led Alaska Airlines
to actually restrict the plane
from flying over
water on long
haul trips
to ensure that
it could return quickly to an airport
if necessary.
On Friday, passengers
describe a violent explosion
when the plane's door plug
blew off shortly
after takeoff from Portland, Oregon.
And then headrests were torn off.
Extra oxygen.
Oxygen masks were sheared off.
Some seats were even twisted
from the force of the depressurization.
One passenger says a child's
shirt was ripped off from it.
Thankfully, the two seats directly next
to what
became a massive hole
were not occupied on this plane.
Also this morning,
a crucial piece of evidence
has been recovered.
The refrigerator sized door plugs
found in someone's backyard in Portland,
but another key piece of
the investigation has been lost.
The cockpit voice recording.
The NTSB says it was
completely overwritten
We can
learn a lot
from that cockpit voice recorder.
We have urged the FAA to extend
the cockpit voice
recorder time
from 2 hours to 25 hours
because we want to hear
communications, noise
alerts on the flight deck,
which may help us prevent
future tragedies.
CNN's Mike Valero is in Portland,
CNN aviation correspondent Pete Meehan.
Pete, Manton is in D.C..
Pete, let's start with you.
What's the latest
on the investigation now?
Well, Kate,
major developments here about this
violent, explosive and terrifying event.
The NTSB
has inspected the interior
and the exterior of the plane
featuring that twisted
and contorted seat metal from that
400 mile
per hour rush of air
through that
refrigerator sized opening
in the left side of the fuselage.
The big development,
this is the smoking gun here.
The piece that fell off of the plane
has been found NTSB chair Jennifer Hamidi
rushed back to the podium last night
to announce
that found in the backyard
of a Portland school teacher.
We only know his first name.
It is Bob
that part is known as a door plug
and it fills a spot on the plane
where an optional door
could be installed at the Boeing factory.
Finding this is key
because it will hold some major clues.
NTSB chair Jennifer Hammond just told me.
Was this a mechanical failure?
Was this a manufacturing defect
by Boeing or its contractors?
That is the key
because this airplane is only months old,
took its first flight.
October 15th, you flew only 150 flights
for Alaska. Airlines.
Investigators also now say
a pressurization warning
light came on in the plane
three times before this incident.
Once just the day before it.
And that caused Alaska
to restrict this plane
from long flights over
water like to Hawaii.
Could have been an early warning.
And it's something that investigators
are probing but are still unclear about.
That alert
that illuminated those three times
certainly
is very disconcerting
to our investigators.
And we want to look at that.
But it may have absolutely nothing to do
with what occurred
in the cabin of the aircraft on that
during that event.
What is missing from this investigation?
The audio
from the cockpit voice recorder
that was overwritten automatically.
How many calls that very disappointing
there's been a push to make recorders
retain information for even longer.
25 hours.
Still a lot of info out there, though.
During the depressurization,
the cockpit door blew open
investigators have been able to tell that
also that the pilots headsets
and checklists
were thrown by the force
of that depressurization.
Alaska Airlines and United Airlines
are the only two U.S.
airlines operating these Boeing.
Seven 37, max nine.
They are still grounded this morning,
awaiting new details on inspections
mandated by the FAA.
United Airlines canceled
270 max nine flights over the weekend.
I want to play for you.
You talked about what
we're normally talking about
as the search
for the black box, the cockpit voice
and data recorders to go through that.
One thing we know here
is that the cockpit voice recorder
very basically have lost
all of the usable
material from it because of how it gets
overwritten
every 2 hours for the control room.
This is a second sound byte.
Let me play with the chair of the NTSB
said about this today, Miles.
We're
disappointed that the
cockpit voice recorder was overwritten.
We can learn a lot from that
cockpit voice recorder.
We have urged the FAA to
extend the cockpit voice recorder time
from 2 hours to 25 hours
because we want to hear
communications, noise
alerts on the flight deck,
which may help us prevent
future tragedies.
Jennifer Hamidi is not happy
that this happened,
that this went down this way.
What could be on there
that is that now is not Miles.
Yeah, you've hit a pet
peeve of mine as well, Kate.
To me, in this day and age,
it's kind of scandalous.
That we only capture
the last 2 hours with digital data
and hard drives.
And we don't
we don't have looped tapes anymore.
We could capture in excess of 24 hours,
as is recommended.
And I'm going to take it
one step further
from the good chairperson and suggest
once again
that we have video cameras
in the cockpits.
The pilots union hates these ideas.
They consider it
invasion of privacy, as they say.
Well, I don't know about you,
but when I'm at work,
I don't consider that a private place.
And if what you're doing
can involve consequences
which lead to the deaths of others,
I think you might have to give up
a little bit of your so-called privacy.
It's high time that we improved
the amount of data
we got out of these
cockpit voice recorders, including video
and for that matter.
It should be streaming
out of the aircraft in real time.
But that's you got me on my high horse.
All right.
We certainly need to discuss this more.
I'm joined now by airline analyst
John Strickland.
He's also the director
of the Air Transport Consulting firm
JLL Consulting.
Thank you so much for coming in
and talking about this today.
Look,
so many of us fly
the seven 37
have been a problem in the past.
They were grounded
I think in 2019 for a year and a half
after a couple of crashes
involving the max eight aircraft
that killed 346 people.
I mean can you give us some sense of
is this a different incident?
Is there something else
wrong with the seven 37?
Is this just a fluke
or is there a major
problem with these seven 37.
Well yes you're right.
The seven 47
Max family
and at that time
it was
the Max Series eight which had the two
tragic fatal crashes
that resulted in that 18 month grounding.
The nine was not in service
at that point,
but is another member of the same family.
The incident of the fuselage panel
the blocked off optional emergency door
that detached off the Alaska Airlines
flight is something
quite different
to the cause of those two fatal crashes.
And the reason for the grounding
that was a piece of software
used by the pilots
on the flight deck
to be called the Marcus system.
It was something which had caused crashes
and which had to be completely reworked
before that aircraft
was able
to get back to being recertified as a
as a safe aircraft
for commercial operation.
It also, of course, affected
Boeing as a company,
which lost an enormous amount of trust
and confidence during that period.
And they had to work hard
to bring that back
and rehabilitate
the aircraft into service.
So last week's incident quite different.
We don't know what caused it yet.
I think as one of your reporters
commented, that it's important.
This is also quite a new aircraft,
only about two months off the
production line.
We wouldn't expect
something like this
to happen
on any well-maintained aircraft,
be it old or young.
But certainly it's particularly
surprising
to get this news of a very new aircraft.
I don't think it reflects a wider problem
with the 7372737 itself
as a type goes back to the 1960s.
It's a tried and tested
aircraft which has been modified updated
into far more advanced
technology versions
such as the max that we're
flying on today.
It's delivered
millions of hours of service,
carried millions of people
around the world.
But that doesn't detract
from the seriousness
of this incident of a need
to get to the bottom of it
as quickly as possible
and keep that
absolutely essential focus on safety
Yeah, I mean, I've certainly
and I know my colleagues
have certainly flown
a lot of seven 30 sevens in our lifetime
with all the traveling that we do.
I do want to ask you about something
the Seattle Times reported that according
to the Alaskan Airlines,
in the days
before this particular incident,
pilots had filed several reports
of warning lights
that indicated
some sort of loss of cabin pressure
and that the plane was restricted
from long distance flight over
water as a result.
Should this plane have just
been grounded, period?
Well, it's
difficult to comment
without knowing more than those facts.
We have heard that
and we heard from the lead
there in your report
of the accident investigation team.
This is something
of interest of concern to them.
There can be many warnings
generated on flights every day.
To pilots.
Largely, these are quite routine
pilots to manage.
They are reported
even directly by the pilots
or more and more these days,
automatically from data systems,
from aircraft flight next to the ground
engineering maintenance control teams.
It's difficult to say more than that.
As to what
the significance
of those pressurization warnings were.
It seems potentially
more than coincidental,
but it could have been something
very, very minor.
It could have been something
completely different.
Pressurization embraces
a lot of elements on an aircraft, but
certainly that needs to be
checked out, worked out
as quickly as possible.
Absolutely.
There's a lot of people
fear of flying is a real thing,
and to see this is terrifying.
John Strickland,
thank you so much for giving us
this analysis.
This morning. Appreciate you.